looking for something new to do this
weekend how about taking your family on
a pedal-powered ride through Nevada
scenic desert JC is live in Boulder City
with all the details hey JC hey ladies
yes we're riding the rails this weekend
I'm not talking about the beautiful
trains behind me we're at the Nevada
Railroad Museum we're talking about the
rail explorers this is Leslie how are
you let's check this out we're not
riding we're not riding the Train we're
riding these rail cars these are pedal
cars yeah and here we go what are we
looking at what's this ride entail all
the way till we get to a little picnic
area
and then I'm gonna have a little
relaxation so you know we've been cooped
up for so long it's a good time and
release all that instant land spin it
around yours I want to go actually show
the rail cars because there's a couple
of options here right we have two Cedars
we got four Cedars to Sears and then
there's four Cedars have you got a
family can come down and pets are
allowed so what what track is everybody
riding on actually this is a very
historic railroad track that they used
to bring the people and the materials
donford Hoover Dam so this is all that
fur in Boulder City for the Hoover Dam
and now the Union Pacific used to own
this and they donated this a Nevada
Railroad Museum and I love to you have
all the social distancing in place we've
got masks on very safe coming out here
to Boulder City their rides they start
back up here again tonight night at 7:30
so we have its night rides so how long
is the ride so we sent some people off
and actually coming up we're gonna get
on on the cars and do it ourselves but
how far and how long is the actual trip
itself gonna be about 20 minutes so
about 20 to 25 minutes it's not a race
because whoever's first just goes ahead
it ends up first at the time and you get
to just travel through all the areas and
see the scenic and it's about you're
gonna pass and you have like a little
picnic area so it's a little picnic area
then you get to get off and you get to
see the train because the train is gonna
come pick us up ladies and gentlemen
that's what I like let's go to the cart
here Lance because oh we had our own
special Channel 8 News we got our own
cart ready for us to go what I love is
yeah we're gonna pedal down here just a
little bit but we don't worry about
pedaling backs I know we're going
downhill which is great you're not
pedaling back you're riding one of the
trains back here to the museum this
really is something this is something
out of a hallmark movie this is
something you would see and yes this is
a home Earth Day and you pedal down but
Jaycee there is a little bit of an
upward hill at the end so we have to
save our energy okay we'll save our
energy we got to wrap it up you're
coming out where you get on the cars
we're gonna do some penalty we're gonna
check it out you've got local discounts
pets are allowed it's all happening in
Boulder City it is the the Railroad
Museum I can't wait to get on one of
these things where I sent it back to you
guys in the studio okay first of all
that looks like a workout for miles
pedaling I know we were saying Michael
say it what if you get a slowpoke in
front of you
yeah stay calm don't don't watch the
road rage get here it's about the
journey though not exact home when you
get when he comes back